acaso esa persona conoce a Jesús o es el
camino hacia él irá también al cielo
está Cristo en cada ser humano diría que
[Música]
no el cristianismo es el único camino a
la salvación 3 2
1 Sí estoy de acuerdo ya que creo que
Jesús es Dios y su vida su muerte y su
resurrección fue la gran redención que
Dios regaló al mundo si lo piensas si
crees que Jesús no es el único camino
estás llamando a Dios idiota porque
crees que vas a decir un día Oh cielos
podrías ir al cielo siendo una buena
persona y gasté toda esta energía y
tiempo para sacrificar a mi propio hijo
Por qué nadie me dijo que había otra
manera quiero decir si hubiera otro
camino Jesús no habría ido a la cruz
crees que es poco perjudicial decir que
llamamos a Dios idiota para aquellos que
no han llegado a esa conclusión todavía
o tal vez a las personas que luchan por
eso porque prefiero pensar que si yo
creciera en un territorio
islámico predominantemente
islámico podríamos decir con confianza
que Seguiremos siendo cristianos me
encanta tu pasión me Temo que nosotros
como cristianos hemos causado mucho daño
por la forma en que hemos como
comunicado las cosas y por no dar a la
gente espacio para ser libres en sus
creencias y
entorno apoyo a la comunidad
lgbtq 3 2
1 solo Tengo curiosidad por saber qué
significa apoyar siento que muchos
cristianos al menos de los que he sido
amigo incluso yo mismo en un momento
dado tendría miedo de decir que apoyo a
la comunidad lgbtq más sé que estamos
llamados a amar a nuestro prójimo Y si
mi vecino es
lgbtq no hay razón para no amarlo
especialmente donde vivimos no invitar a
las personas de esa comunidad a nuestras
Iglesias a nuestras vidas a lo que sea
que hagamos sería una gran pérdida para
la iglesia porque estamos en el mismo
país un grupo demográfico muy grande y
creo que ignorarlo sería una lástima
verán Esa es la cuestión estoy de
acuerdo con todo lo que han dicho porque
sé que Dios los amaama y son un grupo
minoritario que ha sido perseguido
injustamente y creo que nadie debería
ser humillado o golpeado por su
orientación sexual lo que la gente haga
con su vida sexual en su intimidad no es
asunto mío no voy a decir nada sobre eso
no me importa lo que hagan pero cuando
vienen a mi zona y me dicen que mi Dios
piensa que todo eso está bien es cuando
tengo un problema en términos de apoyar
su visión de Dios es lo que no apoyo
creo que lo que dices es una
generalización igual que la gente
generaliza a los cristianos y dice que
los cristianos odian a los gays hay
mucha gente gay a la que literalmente le
importa un bledo lo que crean los
cristianos es más o menos lo mismo por
mucho que queramos amar a la gente y
hayamos experimentado el amor de Jesús y
queramos que otras personas lo
experimenten no voy a amarlos con la
esperanza de que un día se conviertan
solo los amaré creen que ser gay es un
pecado No qué crees que clasifica para
ser parte de la comunidad de gbt
actividad homosexual Bueno yo me
considero que soy gay pero para algunos
cristianos el mero hecho de expresarlo
les horroriza porque creen que ser gay
es un pecado personalmente creo que hay
apegos culturales y sociales al concepto
de ser gay pero si lo llevas al estudio
ser gay Es simplemente la atracción por
el mismo sexo a lo que se refieren es
que abogar por el celibato para la
comunidad lgtbq más si quieren ser
cristianos o no creo que la mayoría de
los cristianos están de acuerdo en que
ser gay no es un pecado pero es más bien
lo que haces con el hecho de ser gay lo
que delimita lo que es pecado y lo que
no lo es incluso diría que no me
corresponde decidir si es correcto que
una persona gay elija ser célibe si
alguien quiere comportarse de cierta
forma puede hacerlo no creo que debo
opinar en ese asunto porque no es mi
vida es su vida sexual entienden lo que
digo porque no opinamos sobre las
relaciones heterosexuales quiero decir
aparte del sexo antes del matrimonio
pero es como si preguntáramos a la gente
qué hac en su tiempo libre creo que una
pregunta que debemos hacernos como
evangélicos es por qué la comunidad
lgbtq no se siente segura en nuestros
espacios y creo que es una pregunta que
debería ser primordial si amamos y
aceptamos a las personas como hechas a
imagen de Dios por qué no se sienten
seguros Y por qué se sienten que tienen
que abandonar nuestros espacios tengo
amigos homosexuales que han abandonado
la iglesia que han dejado el
cristianismo y que forman parte de esta
comunidad y esa es la pregunta con la
que me dirijo a la hora de hablar y
pensar cómo amamos y cuidamos a la
comunidad
lgbtq los medios de comunicación
malinterpretan a los evangélicos o los
caracterizan erróneamente 3 do
Ah
cielos Ah oh Dios lo siento eso es muy
duro siento que los medios de
comunicación a veces pueden centrarse en
los fracasos y en el liderazgo cristiano
y esas cosas en ese sentido Mirando a
estos ejemplos de una manera nos
sentimos retratados en un entorno
frustrado creo que me iría por ese lado
muchas veces los medios de comunicación
negativos que llegan a la iglesia o al
cristianismo se deben a un extremo Si
ves a un grupo haciendo una cosa Eso no
significa que todo el cuerpo de Cristo
lo esté haciendo si se tratara de
cristianos definitivamente estaría en
este bando creo que la razón por la que
elegiría este lado para el término
evangélicos es porque la mayoría el 80%
de ellos votó por Trump Creo que muchas
de las noticias o la cobertura sobre
Quiénes somos y nuestros fracasos es
real y es la cruda realidad de nuestra
iglesia muchos de los problemas que
vemos tenemos que asumirlos creo que
tenemos que pedir perdón por ellos
arrepentirnos y mostrar a la gente Quién
es realmente Jesús aparte de esta
especie de movimiento conglomerado que
tenemos ahora estamos más representados
además hay muchos evangélicos que hacen
un hermoso trabajo que representa Quién
es Jesús y cómo es el reino de Dios pero
creo que tenemos que ser conscientes de
que los medios de comunicación no están
cubriendo cosas inventadas cubren cosas
que están sucediendo en la
iglesia Oh Dios
mío
bien oh
Dios las mujeres deberían poder
desempeñar funciones de liderazgo en la
iglesia 3 do
1 vaya bueno no quería abrir la boca
para que no me saquen de contexto quiero
empezar diciendo que sí creo que las
mujeres son valiosas y cruciales en el
liderazgo de la iglesia y Dios ha
definido los roles de género para la
familia he tenido maravillosas pastoras
predicando en mi iglesia y por eso creo
que las pastoras son excelentes
pero creo que el pastor principal de la
iglesia es el padre de la familia y el
padre es hombre creo que hay una
definición poco precisa de Liderazgo y
no sé si nos referimos a posiciones
específicas dentro de la iglesia pero
siento que incluso en la Biblia hay
muchos casos de mujeres que expresan su
liderazgo como mujer que
está estudiando para ser pastora aprecio
que digas que crees que las mujeres
pueden ser pastoras Sigo pensando que
hay un daño en el ex creo que algo que
dice Jesús o algo de Pablo es que no hay
más hombre ni mujer en última instancia
creo que parte de lo que Jesús trae es
la igualdad donde Antes había
diferencia La Biblia debe ser
interpretada literalmente 3 do
1 creo que interpretar la Biblia
literalmente algo muy propio del
cristianismo occidental y por eso no voy
a decir que una persona que no toma la
Biblia al pie de la letra Está
equivocada sí creo que la Biblia es la
palabra inspirada de Dios y que tenemos
que entenderla pero tenemos que
entenderla en sus contextos y en su
género y asegurarnos de prestar una
atención cuidadosa para no poner solo
nuestra lente occidental así la
trataremos con mayor fidelidad
estoy de acuerdo con eso hay diferentes
géneros no tomo cada texto literal de la
Biblia lo tomo como lo veo Me gustaría
ver su perspectiva sobre los salmos sí
como ella mencionó hay diferentes
géneros como el Apocalipsis No todo es
literal pero la mayoría de lo que dice
la Biblia debe ser tomado al pie de la
letra A eso me refiero con
literal sin embargo todavía hay espacio
para la interpretación con eso es como
si fuera literal Especialmente cuando tu
perspectiva puede ser moldeada tanto por
la educación cultural como social sí
apoyo la anulación de r versus wade 3 2
vaya creo que se puede creer
absolutamente en la santidad de la vida
y en el carácter sagrado de la elección
y cuando se trata de decisiones médicas
no veo Por qué nadie más debería opinar
no hay otras formas en las que el
gobierno regule las decisiones
corporales me parece que solo hace que
el aborto sea inseguro hace que sea
mucho más difícil para las mujeres de
las comunidades de bajos ingresos salir
de sus ciclos y por eso creo que va a
serc mucho más daño que bien y están
viniendo por cosas más allá del aborto
van a empezar a venir por el control de
la natalidad por la anticoncepción ya
han dicho que estas cosas sucederán
trabajarán en ello y es solo el primer
paso para
alcanzarlo de hecho soy probida pero
creo que deberíamos haber invertido más
en el sistema de ida en la atención
sanitaria a las mujeres invertir en una
buena educación saben y en todos estos
ámbitos necesarios para la vida
cualquiera que esté a favor de la vida
debe dar un paso hacia adelante e
invertir más en las mujeres y niños
tenemos que poner el dinero donde está
la boca el tiempo y los recursos esto
acuerdo con eso y como has mencionado
creo que hay muchas matices en torno al
aborto y el caso Row versus wade pero
realmente no lo veo como una cuestión
Evangélica o religiosa lo veo como una
cuestión moral cuando está bien matar a
un bebé y anular el rw versus wave está
mal no creo que ninguna persona a favor
del aborto quiera matar bebés creo que
es un uso muy duro del lenguaje porque
el 70 por de las mujeres que han
abortado se identifican como cristianas
y así al usar un lenguaje como ese
Especialmente cuando viene del púlpito o
lo que sea es dañino porque las mujeres
en las iglesias bancos grupos o donde
estén se han tenido que enfrentar a esa
decisión Así que cuando nosotros como
iglesia usamos un lenguaje tan duro
estamos poniendo un muro una barrera Y
alejando a la gente también Creo que hay
algo
descorazonador en la forma en que se ve
esto ahora todos los hombres están de
este lado y las mujeres del otro lado
personalmente no estoy de acuerdo con
utilizar este tipo de lenguaje porque es
el día más difícil en la vida de algunas
de estas mujeres el día más oscuro Si
pudiera haría algo al respecto porque
tienes razón pero hay muchos matices y
personalmente No las he vivido pero creo
que la pregunta sigue siendo cuándo está
bien Matar un bebé no siento que un
hombre pueda pueda opinar mucho sobre
eso no sé tal vez no sé lo que estoy
haciendo ah difícil y lo entiendo tienes
razón tienes razón si se tratara de
opiniones qué equipo de baloncesto es
mejor Creo que las opiniones no importan
la opinión de todos es la misma pero
como evangélicos nos basamos en lo que
la palabra de Dios nos dice podemos
basarnos en si algo está bien o mal O
podemos decir que podemos estar
equivocados en eso tienes
razón Creo que cualquier persona que sea
probida tiene que ponerse en una
situación en la que se asuma ese coste y
no basta con donar algo de dinero cada
mes y apoyarlo saben creo que todos
tenemos que participar en esto si
seremos probida la iglesia tiene que dar
un paso adelante y la que vaya a todas
esas mujeres directamente para tiene que
entusiasma ver a la iglesia luchar por
la santidad de la vida en todos los
niveles y no solo en términos de la
madre y el bebé también de aquellas
personas con diversas historias de vida
creo que es un tema que se ha politizado
porque parece más
importante proteger a los inmigrantes
que proteger a una mujer que aborta y me
encantaría que como iglesia nos
[Risas]
[Aplausos]